now this is a contradiction but it's
another one in Tai CH it's called the
bird's beak where you put all your
fingers together and the thumb goes the
thumb goes in the
middle the bird's beak goes
over and it's the same as the open
hand so this is as long as you're all
right with contradictions you get on
well in
aikido right because this I'm saying the
complete opposite and I about the
fingers but you don't know what
situation you're in what about if he's
holding my
fingers you know how am I going to oh I
can just I mean you've got to be to
adapt to any
position it comes
up it goes
over and I'm going to go through all
these other
pieces he's on forgotten your name go go
go ko ko yeah oh co that's quick GE
isn't it I dare if I remember if I so if
I say okay it's just backwards yeah I
know
okay so he's on the line his arms on the
line and this is what's happening those
who can see it you're sort of turning
over and it's going this side of the
line and then by the time you get there
it's G on that side of the
line and you you know you third down and
above really should be keeping it
exactly on the line and you should be
moving you should be
moving so bird's beak over out all right
so this now isn't that isn't
that so so don't get confused by going
here here oh I need to open my fingers
cuz it you know it's not going to be
right is
it strong
that's when you open your
fingers when you when you're going to
let your full tiger out of
the can't get out is because I
again still on the
line right the more they hold the more
you'll find that it will vary where it's
going keep it where it
is and you'll get it okay so the bird's
beak it goes over under and
out okay d